اصبحت بخموت مدينه النمو مدمره بالكامل
والسكان يعيشون تحت وقع القصف المتوسط قبل
الحرب كان يعيش بالمدينه حاول 80,000 شخص
لم يعد عددهم يتجاوز اليوم ال 10,000
صوت القذف لا يحتمل لا نستطيع النوم كما
انه لم يعد لدينا نوافذ في المنزل لقد
قمنا بتغطيتها حتى نحمي انفسنا من طلقات
الرصاص لقد اصبحت استيقظ صباحا في الظلام
لم يكن احد يتوقع هذا
بس انا اه
علمتني هذه المركبات المستاجره من قبل
المنظمات الانسانيه تستمر عمليات الاجلاء
بصعوبه بالغه اما على الجانب الاخر من
المدينه وعلى خط المواجهه يسعى الجميع
للمساعده هذه المجموعه تطبخ طوال الليل
لتقديم الطعام للجنود
لقد حذرنا الحلوى والعديد من الاطباق يجب
ان ندعم الجنود الذين يحاربون من اجل
حريتنا
مهم
المعارك قد تزداد حده في الاسابيع المقبله